for all of our certifications we list
out kind of a preparation path on our
certification pages I think that focuses
primarily on what are the trainings what
are the resources that we can give you
we give some recommendations for
hands-on labs we also recommend using
the JCP free tier or you know any
resources that we have to get you into
the products and tools that you'll be
assessed on I think if you in addition
to that need some additional
professional experience what we
recommend is just using the exam guide
to see what topics are going to be
assessed and kind of doing a
self-evaluation make sure that you're
there with those skills and it might
mean that you should you know wait six
months or a year while you are getting
those additional skills before you
attempt the exam but using the exam
guides and those resources kind of helps
you set that benchmark it helps you know
where you're at so that then you can
prepare better as you're looking at the
certification
you